(dramatic orchestral music)
- Monster headaches.
- I'm so tired.
- Lashing out.
- [Woman in Gray] We want fucking water!
- Stop torturing me.
- There's a psychological component.
- I might die doing this. I
literally might die doing this.
(woman screaming)
(dramatic music crescendos)
- Coffee is life. Life
is coffee. (sips coffee)
- Like, on a normal day, I'm dehydrated.
I'm probably dehydrated right now.
- I don't know how to
watch Netflix without wine.
- I'm addicted to coffee.
I love soda on the weekend.
- I really hope to not be
dehydrated all the time.
- I'd like to know what it
feels like to feel healthy.
- I wanna be not addicted to caffeine.
- I feel really sluggish in
the afternoons around 2 or 3,
and I'm hoping that maybe
if I just go all water
I'll have some more energy.
- I can do this, 100%. (laughs)
- Good morning, everybody.
So, got my water, I'm ready to do this,
I'm feelin' pretty good.
Actually, I'm pretty
excited. Let's do this!
Healthy living: day one.
It's day three. I feel
like I'm dying right now.
Can I chew, like, coffee
beans for caffeine?
- I went into this really
confident, but this is actually
one of the hardest things I've ever done.
I'm so tired. And all I
wanna do is drink coffee.
- I have had a ton of withdrawal.
I just feel terrible.
- Monster headaches,
lashing out at other people for no reason.
- To me, I feel like this was
probably the toughest week.
Cause it was the change.
I feel like now I'm sorta
getting used to not having tea.
But the biggest bummer,
I think, was socializing.
- [Voiceover] David. How's
that water thing coming, buddy?
- The water thing is just great,
and I was just getting
some water right now.
- Which water were you gonna get in there?
- And don't you guys
have jobs or something?
Don't you have jobs? Get to your jobs.
- Eating and drinking are
so tied to my social life.
It's difficult to be at
breakfast and just drinking water
and everyone else is drinking, like,
a coffee or some orange juice.
- This challenge is the
worst possible thing.
I've gained weight.
- The fact that I'm drinking so much water
makes me feel entitled to
make choices like nachos.
I guess when I came into
this I was kinda hoping
that I would notice more energy,
or notice something significant
about the way I feel change
and that hasn't happened.
- I also haven't been super
good about not drinking alcohol.
I just wanna have fun on a
Friday after the difficult week
so I've had a few drinks.
(buzzer)
and then I went to karaoke and
drank a lot. (laughs)
(bouncy pop music)
- So we're gonna play some kind of
weird mash-up of Capture the Flag and tag?
(woman screaming and laughing)
- I feel okay, I feel pretty fine.
I'm not too tired, so maybe I have been
a lot more hydrated
these past three weeks.
- Since I've started, the only
water thing I have noticed:
the wall I hit at 3 or 4
pm has kind of gone away.
- I've been managing my sleep better,
so I force myself to go
to bed at a certain time
if I know that the next
day I have to get up early.
Cause usually I'll just use
coffee to cover all that up.
- I also didn't realize
just how often in my life
alcohol is just around, and
more often than not, free.
In this past week I was
at three different parties
where people were offering
me lots of free alcohol.
Stop torturing me.
- This is way harder than I
thought it was going to be.
This is just, this has been the worst.
(dramatic orchestral music)
- I'm about to explode
with happiness. Oh my gosh!
(people sipping drinks)
- It's been a long time.
(Steven sighs)
- This is great.
It is before 11:30 in the morning.
- It's one week out and I feel
tired, still, all the time.
I feel like coffee should
really affect me now,
but I feel like now I'm
just desensitized to it.
- Doing this life change was really good
because now any future
life changes I wanna make
I'm a little more prepared for.
- My base lesson is that water should be
what you drink as a baseline.
- I can't tolerate coffee anymore.
Which is so sad and so difficult.
You're forcing me to be hydrated
and not have an excessive
amount of caffeine.
You...
You messed with my life.
(laughing) You've changed my life.
(bell tone)